let's jump to the story from Tim
cast.com Trump files motion to dismiss
January 6 case citing Double Jeopardy in
First Amendment this is interesting uh
former president Donald Trump has asked
the US District Court of Columbia to
dismiss special counsel Jack Smith's
case against him for his alleged role in
the events of January 6 citing the first
amendment in Double Jeopardy quote if
there is any constant in our democratic
system of governance it is that the
marketplace of ideas not the mandates of
government functions functionaries or
partisan prosecutors determines the
scope of public debate stated Trump's
reps in a filing countless Millions
Believe As Trump uh consistently has and
currently does that fraud and irregular
irregularities pervaded the 2020
presidential election as the indictment
itself alleges president Trump gave
voice to those concerns and demanded
that politicians in a position to
restore Integrity to our elections not
just talk about the problem but
investigate and solve it so I think what
they're saying uh here's a quote
additionally as the United States Senate
has previously tried and acquitted
president Trump for charges arising from
the same course of conduct alleged in
the indictment the impeachment and
double Jeopardy Clauses both bar retrial
before this court and require dismissal
is that true I mean I'm not the
Constitutional lawyer I think on freedom
of speech and First Amendment grounds he
should
because if you're not well the two-tier
system of justice again right if you're
Nancy Pelosi Hakim Jeff Hillary Clinton
you can say the election was stolen the
elction was rigged this whole process
sucks I didn't win wah wah wah and then
if you're Donald Trump you're going to
prison so on that just basis Alone by
the way this judge could not be more
corrupt and bias we can get into that if
you want to is that yeah I've literally
been before her um but the double
jeopardy here's a here's a really crazy
thing about duber Jeopardy and I only
know this because I paid attention for
like 7even seconds in law school to try
to pass the bar exam you can be charged
in state and federal court for the exact
same thing it's not Double Jeopardy you
just can't be charged in federal court
twice for the same thing or or the same
state I'm assuming like or the same
Juris right right exactly so on Double
Jeopardy grounds he's good if he's
saying No this needs to go because you
already are alleging this in the south
Florida case in Miami uh it's got to go
then he's got a strong point I just
these are both Federal then these are
both Federal this has to do with the
Miami DC case and if they're going to
bring more charges or not well he was so
in and bringing up um it's interesting
impeachment is not the criminal case the
the the argument is first they would
impeach Donald Trump then convict him
and then after he convicted they can
file the criminal indictment and seek to
convict them on criminal charges where
in Congress so so the arguments as to
why Donald Trump can't be criminally
charged yet is that he has to be
impeached for these things first but
he's been criminally charged and right
so so the the argument is uh uh I can't
remember who wrote this um we covered it
several oh I see the legal gymnastics
you're talking about like there's a
constitutional argument that you can't
criminally charge uh uh like like
members of the Trump Administration or
Trump himself because it's
it's it's it's the executive branch you
have to seek impeachment argument
being the president has broad leeway in
in taking actions for the benefit of
this country or the direction of this
country and if you believe the president
has done wrong by this country you have
to impeach him which is the statement of
I challenge I I I hereby accuse you of
wrong crimes and misdemeanors then the
Senate convicts him for doing it then
after we all agree the president has
broken his oath of office or whatever
yeah you then file criminal charges
against him that's a pretty good
constitutional argument I mean it makes
the most sense cuz cuz what if you if
that was not the case any blue State
could file criminal charges against the
president any time it's state charges oh
the president committed a crime and and
what how are we supposed to have a
president if what like think about the
Civil War when the states were upset
with Lincoln pre- Civil War and the
fears about imagine if if if Virginia or
Alabama was just like we're criminally
charging the president well you couldn't
that that the argument he has to be
impeached which is the agreement the
president has committed High crimes and
misdemeanors and then is removed from
office more so than just the I'll put
this way if that is not the standard
then there is no president a single
state could challenge the results of an
election by criminally charging a
president for anything so you need a
federal level impeachment against him
before you can try and criminally charge
him at a state level well you're not
also not supposed to be ever to be able
to charge him while he's sitting in
office so it's going to be even
interesting if he wins 2024 and what are
you going to
do well that's that that's that's
exactly the argument uh they're making
is that the actions they are charging
Trump over happened while he was
president in which case I agree with
that he should be immune from that
prosecution because until he's convicted
an impeachment Tri right then Tri U so
totally on board with that because he
was in the white house he was he was
still there saying whatever he was
allowed to say and that's protected but
and and I would I would I would say this
too uh the reason why I have nothing but
disgust for for those lawyers like Jenna
Ellis and Cy Powell is is that it is a
it is not just a constitutional duty to
provide legal counsel to an individual
it is not just a legal duty to provide
counsel to someone who is Seeking a
redress of grievances it is an
obligation for Donald Trump if he
believes the election was stolen to
pursue all legal methods to investigate
and and seek remedy that would mean any
lawyer who is taking up that job has a
duty to this country to make sure that's
the case for Jenna Ellis to have lied in
what in her previous statements that she
believed or that that that she you in
her Arguments for Sydney Powell to have
lied or to have flipped now they are
basically saying the fabric of this
nation means less to them than their
personal Comfort yeah and what you're
also saying is that a president a
sitting president is not entitled to
counsel is that the precedent we want to
set is that the historical Foundation we
want to set because you disagree with
him politically and that decision should
be adjudicated at the polls and not in
the courts of law are we going to now
when President Trump say he wins in 2024
are we going to go back and arrest based
on this doj's precedent every Joe Biden
attorney that worked against electing
president Donald Trump and provided
advice to Joe Biden saying it was okay
to take classified documents out of the
you know when you were Vice President
Senator I mean that's what they want us
to do and I think they don't care
because the mainstream media will cover
for them and it'll just be orange man
bad but it's a
of Justice they don't care well uh the
argument is a three- tiered you've got
uh the people who get away with
everything the regular people that get
ignored and never get any attention and
then the people who are arrested for
everything you know so there are a lot
of people who have have talked about
going to the police for help because of
crimes and they are completely ignored M
that's true go to DC is a big reason a
lot of this go is going on that right
now given the way approval rates are
sitting are they worried that undecided
voters who are looking for something
different who may are like look four
years have gone by I maybe you forget a
little bit of like a lot of these people
who maybe didn't vote for Donald Trump
in 2020 four years have gone by things
have gotten bad enough now that maybe
they're like maybe I'm willing to go
back to that is the idea to keep this in
the news keep him in trial not just in
an actual trial but the court of public
opinion to keep voters from wanting to
swing back and possibly give him a shot
this time around because you keep
dirtying them up by keeping them in the
news with all these Cycles well that's
the Hope look remember the Democrats
aren't stupid they're evil and they're
Wicked and they're Geniuses at certain
points in time when they collaborate
together they don't want Joe Biden to be
their candidate they they might not
publicly say that but they're not
they're not morons what they're trying
to do is both dirty up Trump and Biden
at the same time and then they're going
to be like no no we're you know we're
going after both people but they want to
give Joe Biden an exit ramp it's not a
it's not a coincidence they're no
coincidences in government major theme
in my book that David Ignatius of the
Washington freaking post comes out and
says oh Joe Biden you've done so well
but please retire now that's not a
coincidence that means the FBI doj gave
David ignacius the details of Hunter
Biden's criminal case and Joe Biden's
criminal case and said if we don't get
this guy out this is what's coming and
then we're going to indict him but if we
just charge
Hunter and we force daddy Biden to
commute his sentence that's it game over
he can't be president I I I think
there's a decent probability that uh Joe
Biden gets indicted for the reasons you
just outlined they might have to go to
that I'm saying that's their last option
it's it's it's their but it's their
plausibility shield for middle of the
road uninitiated they'll go to De Mer
Garland who looks like a wet noodle
every time he approaches a microphone
him and him and Chris Ray the worst FBI
director in history will go to the
microphone and said we charge two
sitting presidents or whatever one
former we're not biased we're not biased
this charging Biden too we everybody
Biden's a criminal and I think they
Biden is the sacrificial lamb it could
come I think Hunter's their leverage
point I think they get to that but
here's the thing they got to figure all
this stuff out in the next 990 days once
you get past the Iowa caucuses they
can't air mail in Gavin Newsome the guy
they want to come in to be president
technically if Joe Biden is incapable of
running it's something something will
happen I mean you're you're right in
terms of a primary yeah uh
but they'll they'll they'll they'll
they'll make it happen you know what I
mean but that's what I'm saying that's
why the these articles are starting to
come out from left-wing organizations
that's not random no government has
called him and said hey this is coming
we need you to help us Grease the skids
get rid of this guy politely and then
we'll we'll glorify him for being the
Savior from Trump that's what they will
literally write about him for decades to
come if this play happens and half of
America will buy it that's why I kind of
think a medical issue is the is the more
likely out for Joe Biden well you just
have to watch him on TV for like 30
seconds if you want a medical issue but
how do you uh uh how do you get kamla
Harris uh out of the way how do you get
Joe Biden to not run and how do you get
a Gavin Newsome in Joe Biden has a
medical issue Gavin Newsome runs out on
stage performs CPR saves the life of the
president I mean think about it and then
KLA Harris assumes the role acting
president for the remainder of the year
but then says I really want to take that
senate seat in California I need to
return to my home no no no she's going
to go take her $10 million payday but
what you'll say is I I I am honored to
have served this country asent I took
out Trump with Biden the greatest Victor
right you and I I believe it the cards
for me to pursue an election with such
short notice so I'd like to honor you
know with honor and humility offer up
Gavin Newsome and ask him to to lead
this nation and then you get a Gavin
Newsome that's why Newsome's probably
when when's he he's debating uh Des on
the 30th which November November no I
for for for tater Ron to go in there and
and accept this debate just shows you
the disparity of where these two
individual are you want you want to know
my conspiracy theory is you yes I do but
once you know what hilarious for your
audience
I go to engagements around the country
for for Donald Trump all the time and do
big events whatever what you know Ronda
sandz should call in for presidency when
he could put more people a room than
cash Patel I mean this have you seen his
events it's sad here's what I think a
year and a half ago we were talking
about Ron being president I mean tons of
outlets were before Trump announced
before he's back in the game and there
was conversations when Trump was
announcing that a trump disantis ticket
would be unstoppable before STIs I
remember being part of those
conversations here's my Conspiracy
Theory special interests who uh uh
establishment interests knew that was
the case probably looked at the polling
data and says Trump's a wild card that
piss people off but Des Santa stabilizes
his numbers by being that more boring
regular politician we need to make sure
they can never form that ticket so they
go to Dan santis whisper sweet nothings
in his ears and and you and I wondered
this I say it's a conspiracy I'm not
saying it's I literally believe it's
absolute I'm saying just entertain the
the interesting thought based on this if
you look at what Ronda Sis's campaign
has been like your only conclusion could
be that he is being sabotaged have you
seen him wearing the high heels oh the
cowboy boots with the big lifts big
lifts is an
understatement he should have just gone
straight to platforms you know the the
the the front of the boot is flat and
bent like there's no foot in it his it
looks like his foot is pressed up
against the front of the boot and
there's a 4-in lift in them now I'm not
saying I know for a fact that's true but
these are the memes that coming out you
look at how um you know Ashley stclair
made a joke about it and Christina P
starts attacking her and I'm like is is
are like are they intentionally nuking
the first thing I said was I believe
that Ron Ronda tent's campaign staff are
secret Trump supporters who are
intentionally nuking his campaign to
help Trump then I thought about it I'm
like maybe the real goal is to stop Dan
santz from having teamed up with Trump
in the first place cuz now that
relationship is is uh Beyond repair yeah
it's nuked it's yeah and and I don't I
don't really understand why it would not
have been good for I know there's that
whole thing you know if you have your
moment in politics you don't want to
miss it but would DeSantis have suffered
from being vice president you know I
don't think he would I mean he can't be
Governor again right isn't he term
limited so where does he go vice
presidency is not a bad idea especially
to gain official exposure on the
national stage or you or you give him a
secretarial position in the cabinet
secretary agriculture whatever right
educationeducation have have it out for
like two years or four years and you'd
still only be 46 you know at the time of
the end of the second Trump
Administration you can run in but I
think there's it's not a conspiracy so
you got to look at DES Sis's top three
donors Ken Griffin from Citadel number
one he's now actually conveniently
stopped giving Ron money but when it
first started they went all in on the
super pack and I know the guys running
that super pack they were always never
trumpers and Trump haters and flipped
the wagon as soon as it became
convenient for them and they were the
ones out there in the media saying we
are going to be the ones that saved the
Republican party from Donald Trump and I
remember everybody excoriating Trump for
being like you can't make fun of Ron you
can't call him dis sanctimonious which
is not the best nickname I will say I
mean but here's the effect right whether
it was a best nickname or not Trump's
strategy was to kneecap him before that
guy ever got out of the gate and and
everybody in the political Arena was
saying this is not going to work and Ron
Ron literally puts less people in a room
than I do if I send out one true social
post sounds like they said if if Trump
gets to S us on the ticket he's going to
we can't beat him there's nobody who can
run against him by no nobody and so they
were like let's let's go to to santis
and offer him tons of money and tell him
he's the guy it's it's his it's his path
convince him and then once he betrays
Trump that's it we're done and then they
walk away and they stop giving him money
isn't he like number five now already
like on the on the what do you call it
the GOP Stakes he's not even like the
second guy I think he's number three in
the prediction Market but but you you
mentioned this the owners have stopped
giving him money they p and that was a
while ago and then he had that mass
layoff like they barely gave him any
money at all it's kind of crazy but
don't worry when he debates Gavin
Newsome who by the way will probably
clobber him like you I don't like Gavin
Nome but he's charismatic he's smart and
he knows how to speak and debate and
that's going to be I'll actually that'll
be the one debate I watch I won't watch
any of the GOP ones uh but I'll watch
that one look at this uh uh Nikki Haley
is in second place in the prediction
Market I never would have saw that
coming I got to be honest she's doing
well New Hampshire last day checked
that's it's also hard for Ron to push
back against Trump when it comes to like
the the social media presence because he
is supposed to be this traditional
politician that was more of a uh quiet
mind you know quiet yeah like so it's a
lot harder in the social media age when
everything's a meme to push back when
people are saying that you're wearing
high heels how do you how does somebody
dignifi you know use dignity to get
their way out of that right so he said
that the the people that work for him
then say to Ashley Sinclair oh you're
you're being rude for doing something
like this when that's that's not going
to work not in the social media age I
mean you'd hope that he'd lean into the
fact that he's young and be like you
crazy kids on social media with your
jokes and your ideas but instead it was
just this crazy serious thing I mean
like he could have gone boot shopping on
Tik Tok and or like on reals or whatever
and it might have been better but the
the it really feels to me like the
undercurrent of what's around him is
looking for a fight and they're feeling
insecure and again I actually feel like
you know I I always say that we I don't
want to short the bench right like if
Trump is elected he will only he'll be a
one-term president and he could do
incredible things but we have to keep
the momentum going there has to be
people after him and so whether it's
Ronda Sanz or not we don't need it to be
this crazy infighting led by people who
are feeling insecure about their
campaign funny too cuz didn't like Logan
Paul did the thing with vake and it
became his biggest social media platform
to to push his campaign ideas like Ron
probably would have been better off
figuring out a way to actually lean into
the social media aspect of it better
like this picture right here who is that
it's I don't know but like doesn't it
you look at his boots and they're on the
ground but it does look like he's on his
TI his tippy toes it's just much more
disarming to people to laugh with them
right and that's that's that's the
reality here but doesn't that break his
his image right His Image is supposed to
be the person who uh institutes policy
and then doesn't feel the need to have
to clap back that's what they liked
about him right like the fact that he
was not the reactionary of trump he end
up clapping back and he could have been
the guy that is like oh I'm so dignified
haha I'll laugh with you no but you're
right you know you rais a good point
like he could have just waited it out a
hot second been on a meteoric rise and
would have been the dude you know come
2028 whatever that math is instead not
only is he not the dude now he's never
going to be the dude in this generation
like he's 45 so maybe at 65 he could
make a play like Trump did maybe in his
70s but right now now he's gone this
Republican party is completely different
the people in the State of Florida have
to everybody's like oh Rona s doing a
great job in the State of Florida he is
yeah but do you know the vote structure
in the State of Florida in 2022 Ronda
santis got 4 million votes in the State
of Florida in
2022 Donald J Trump got 5.1 million
votes in the State of
Florida in 2022 2020 2020 excuse me so
when the year they were both on ticket
that's the spread in the State of
Florida he was also losing a lot of the
America first people right cuz they were
like look neocon like they they
immediately smelled neocon on him
anyways yeah and and had a lot of
questions about it so he had a lot he
would have had a lot of ground to make
up there anyways yeah I mean there are
things that and I remember saying this
at like at this time a year ago that
there were things that I thought D
santis could bring to let's say a debate
stage and talk about really
interestingly I mean Florida is unique
in the sense that it deals with a lot of
illegal immigrations that's unique to
that region right they have a lot of uh
immigration from they have a lot of
immigration from oh good homie sorry
Rona sis just sent me sends his team
just sent me a message for a a donor
event in Las Vegas where I live I was
like do you guys even know who you're
sending this stuff to anymore like I'm
just are you going to go maybe you know
why not you know maybe I'll go in there
and go walk into treasure ask him about
his boots I can ask him about his boots
the funny thing is it's in Treasure
Island which is Phil Ruffin's Place
who's Donald Trump's best friend I find
this all hilarious be like 3in heel 3in
lifts or 4
just take a picture next to him cuz we
were trying to figure out the and look
and and I and I I was personally
offended as somebody who's short you
know I wanted him to win the short vote
you wanted representation I wanted
representation I wanted him to win the
short vote thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net